BY COMING ON HERE.
THANK YOU.
>> THANKS.
>> Tucker: APPRECIATE IT.
GOING TO GO TO ANOTHER STORY
THAT'S BEEN BREWING TONIGHT.
FOR WEEKS, AS YOU KNOW,
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
HOLDING HEARINGS.
THEY'VE BEEN WIDELY COVERED ON
THE OTHER CHANNELS, WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THE NEWS VALUE IN THEM.
BUT THERE IS A BIT OF NEWS TO
EMERGE FROM THAT STORY, AND WE
WANT TO GET TO IT NOW.
SO THE NEAR TIMES HAS WRITTEN
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
ARTICLES ABOUT JANUARY 6TH AS IT
HAPPENED, DESCRIBING IT AS A
RIOT, AND INSURRECTION.
IT'S PART OF ITS COVERAGE, LEFT
SOME ARE THEY PUBLISHED A VIDEO
DOCUMENT OR IN WHICH THE TIMES
REPORTED THAT ONE MAN WAS
ACTUALLY CAUGHT ON CAMERA
PLANNING AND INSURRECTION,
ENCOURAGING A BREACH OF THE
CAPITAL COMPLEX.
THAT MAN'S NAME IS RAY APPS.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" NOTED THAT
HE WAS VIDEOTAPED ON BOTH
JANUARY 5TH AND JANUARY 6TH
URGING PROTESTERS TO SWARM THE
CAPITAL.
HERE IT IS.
>> WE NEED TO GO IN LEAP TO THE
CAPITAL.
LET'S GO!
I'M PROBABLY GOING TO GO TO JAIL
FOR IT!
TOMORROW WE NEED TO GO INTO THE
CAPITAL!
INTO THE CAPITAL!
>> NO!
>> SPREAD THE WORD.
AS SOON AS THE PRESIDENT STOPPED
SPEAKING, WE GO TO THE CAPITAL.
CAPITAL IS THIS DIRECTION.
>> Tucker: IN A LOT OF WAYS,
THAT'S THE STRANGEST VIDEO TO
EMERGE FROM JANUARY 6.
WE'VE PLAYED IT SEVERAL TIMES ON
THE SHOW.
"WE NEED TO GO INTO THE CAPITAL
COME INTO THE CAPITAL," HE TELLS
THE CROWD.
HE SAYS IT REPEATEDLY.
HE IS SO EMPHATIC ABOUT IT,
ENCOURAGING OTHER PEOPLE TO
COMMIT A CRIME.
THE CROWD AROUND HIM THE SITES
MUST BE A FEDERAL AGENT.
THEY BEGAN CHANTING, AS YOU JUST
HEARD.
SHORTLY AFTER THE VIDEO SURFACED
THE FBI PLACED HIM ON A LIST OF
PEOPLE WANTED FOR QUESTIONING.
THEY RELEASED HER TO THE PUBLIC
AND YOU CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THEY
DID THAT.
ACCORDING TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, WHAT HE DID ON THAT
VIDEO IS A FEDERAL CRIME.
IN FACT, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS CHARGED
SEVERAL PEOPLE WITH SEDITIOUS
CONSPIRACY FOR DOING PRECISELY
WHAT YOU JUST SAW RAY APPS DO,
URGING OTHERS TO ENTER THE
CAPITAL COMPLEX ON JANUARY 6.
HERE, FOR EXAMPLE, IS THE QUOTE
FROM A DOJ PRESS RELEASE THAT
DESCRIBES THE FEDERAL CASE
AGAINST FIVE MEMBERS OF THE
SO-CALLED PROUD BOYS.
A GROUP YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
TERRIFIED OF.
"ON JANUARY 6, 2021, THE
DEFENDANTS DIRECTED, MOBILIZED,
AND LED NUMBERS OF THE CROWD
ONTO THE CAPITAL GROUNDS AND
INTO THE CAPITAL."
AGAIN, THAT'S WHAT YOU JUST SAW
RAY APPS TRIED TO DO.
HERE'S THE DIFFERENCE, OTHERS
WHO HAVE DONE THAT ARE IN PRISON
OR FACING LONG TERM IN PRISON.
BUT NO CHARGES HAVE EVER BEEN
FILED AGAINST HIM DESPITE THE
FACT THERE IS NO QUESTION HE DID
IT.
THAT'S VERY STRANGE.
IT JUST IS.
IT IS STRANGE AND WE WOULD LIKE
AN ANSWER TO WHAT THE HECK IS
GOING ON.
WE'D ASKED RAY APPS ON THIS
SHOWED REPEATEDLY TO EXPLAIN WHY
HE THINKS HE HAS ESCAPED
PROSECUTION AND WE WILL ASK HIM
ONCE AGAIN TONIGHT AND WE WILL
KEEP ASKING, WE THINK IT IS A
VERY OBVIOUS AND ABORTIVE
QUESTION THAT GETS TO THE HEART
OF WHAT IS THIS EXACTLY.
BUT IT'S AMAZING HOW LITTLE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
THIS.
AGAIN, NANCY PELOSI AND LIZ
CHENEY HAVE SPENT THE LAST YEAR
STAGING INVESTIGATION AT GREAT
EXPENSE AND THEN A SERIES OF
PUBLIC SHOW TRIALS ARRESTING
PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES,
SUPPOSEDLY DESIGNED TO DISCOVER
HOW AND WHY JANUARY 6 HAPPENED.
BUT THEY REMAIN CURIOUSLY
UNINTERESTED IN THE APPS CASE
WE GOT WHAT SEEMS LIKE AN ACTUAL
INSURRECTIONIST ON TAPE BUT THEY
DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT AND
I DEFINITELY DON'T WANT YOU TO
TALK ABOUT IT OR ASK ANY
QUESTIONS.
AS IF TO PROVE THAT POINT,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" JUST RAN A
PIECE EXPLAINING THAT WHEN YOU
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT RAY APPS,
YOU ARE COMMITTING A MORAL
CRIME, MAYBE EVEN HELPING PUTIN.
THE PIECE WAS ENTITLED "IT'S
JUST BEEN HELL: LIFE AS THE
VICTIM OF A JANUARY 6TH
CONSPIRACY THEORY."
SO RAY EPPS, THE GUY TELLING
PEOPLE TO BREACH THE CAPITAL, IS
NOW IN THE WORDS OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," A VICTIM,
VICTIM OF YOUR UNRESTRAINED
CURIOSITY.
THIS PIECE WAS WRITTEN BY A
REPORTER WHO HAS SPENT YEARS
SHOWING OPENLY FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
IT MAY GIVE YOU SOME SENSE OF
WHERE THE STORY COMES FROM.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE WAS
HIGHLY DECEPTIVE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE MERE TIME SAYS
THAT HE WAS TAPED URGING PEOPLE
TO GO TO THE CAPITAL.
OH, BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT THE TAPE
SHOWS.
RAY EPPS WAS DOING SOME THING
VERY DIFFERENT, HE WAS URGING
PEOPLE TO GO INTO THE CAPITAL,
NOT TO THE CAPITAL.
AND THERE'S A BIG DIFFERENCE
LEGALLY.
ONE IS A CRIME ACCORDING TO THE
DOJ AND THE OTHER IS NOT A
CRIME.
THAT'S NOT ALL RAY EPPS DID.
HE ALSO TOLD THEM WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO ONCE THEY GOT INSIDE
THE CAPITAL AND THIS IS JUST
MINUTES BEFORE THE FIRST BREACH
OF THE BUILDING THAT DAY.
WATCH.
THEY GO CAN WE GO UP THERE?
NO?
>> WHEN WE COME IN --
>> ARE WE GOING TO GET ARRESTED
>> Tucker: LEAVE THIS HERE,
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
FOR SOME REASON THE MAYOR TIMES
REPORTED DIDN'T ASK RAY EPPS
WHAT HE MEANT BY THAT.
REPORTER SPENT A DAY TALKING TO
EPPS.
IT WAS A DAYLONG CONVERSATION
ACCORDING TO THE STORY.
THAT QUESTION NEVER CAME UP.
NO MEANINGFUL QUESTION CAME UP.
IT'S ALL VERY STRANGE.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS MOUNTING
A PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN ON BEHALF
OF A SELF-DESCRIBED TRUMP VOTER
INSURRECTIONIST.
THIS IS THE SAME PAPER THAT
CHEERED ASHLEY BABBITT'S DEATH,
BUT THE SAME PAPER IS REAPING
FOR RAY EPPS -- WEEPING FOR RAY
EPPS BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE MEAN TO
HIM AMONG?
IT'S ALL MOST LIKE THEY'RE COVER
SOMETHING UP.
VERY NEAR THE END OF
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE
THERE'S A HINT, WE FIND THIS
LINE.
"MR. EPPS ALSO SAID HE REGRETTED
SENDING A TEXT OF HIS NEPHEW
WELL AFTER THE VIOLENCE HAD
ERUPTED IN WHICH HE DISCUSSED
HOW HE HAD HELPED ORCHESTRATE
THE MOVEMENTS OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
LEAVING MR. TRUMP'S BEACH NEAR
THE WHITE HOUSE BY POINTING THEM
IN THE DIRECTION OF
THE CAPITOL."
REALLY?
BUT WAS IN THAT TEXT?
WE NEVER HEARD OF THAT BEFORE,
AND A KIND OF MAKES YOU THINK
THE ENTIRE "NEW YORK TIMES"
PIECE WAS WRITTEN TO DROP THAT
LITTLE BOMB AT THE END IN THE
LEAST DAMAGING WAY.
WE'VE NEVER SEEN THAT TEXT
MESSAGE BEFORE.
WHAT EXACTLY DID RAY EPPS SAY TO
HIS NEPHEW?
HAVE PROSECUTORS REVIEWED THAT
TEXT?
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DOESN'T
TELL US.
NOR DOES "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
TELL US WHETHER RAY EPPS' HAD
ANY CONTACT WITH ANY FEDERAL
AGENCIES IN THE PERIOD BEFORE
JANUARY 6.
THE CORE QUESTION.
BUT THEY DIDN'T ASK IT.
WHY IS THAT?
SEEMS LIKE A MAJOR OMISSION.
BUT DON'T ASK MORE QUESTIONS,
OTHERWISE RAY EPPS MAY BE KILLED
BY MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS.
MEXICAN DRUG CARTELS?
WHAT DID THEY HAVE TO DO WITH
THIS?
WE ARE NOT SURE, BUT ACCORDING
TO THE PAPER THERE ARE PEOPLE
HAVE HEARD "SOME CARTEL MEMBERS
TALK ABOUT KILLING MR. EPPS."
RIGHT, BECAUSE THE DRUG CARTELS
ARE COMMITTED TRUMP VOTERS AND
THEY FEEL BETRAYED BY RAY EPPS?
MAYBE THEY ARE QUEUING ON PEOPLE
TOO?
THIS IS HIGHLY STRANGE, AND IF
YOU'RE GOING TO SPEND MORE THAN
A YEAR LOOKING INTO JANUARY 6
AND YOU IGNORE THIS, THEN IT'S
MORE THAN STRANGE.
IT'S AN INDICTMENT OF YOUR
MOTIVES.
ONE OF THE REASONS THIS PIECE
WAS FIRST WRITTEN, THE EDITOR OF
ROBBER NEWS, WHICH PUBLISHED THE
FIRST STORIES ABOUT RAY EPPS.
I WAS LEAVING "NEW YORK TIMES"
IS VERY WORRIED ABOUT HIS
REPORTING AND WE ARE HAPPY TO
HAVE HIM JOIN US TONIGHT.
DARREN, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> WELL, IT'S PRETTY REMARKABLE.
I MEAN LET'S TAKE ALL OF THIS
IN.
THE ONE PERSON CAUGHT REPEATEDLY
URGING PEOPLE INTO THE CAPITOL
AS EARLY AS JANUARY 5TH IS THE
ONE PERSON OF ALL OF THE JANUAR.
TO THAT "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
JUST HAPPENS TO WRITE THIS ULTRA
SYMPATHETIC PUFF PIECE FOR.
IT'S QUITE REMARKABLE, AND TO
LOOK AT THE PIECE ITSELF, AS YOU
SUGGESTED IN YOUR INTRO, THERE'S
SOME REAL GLARING OMISSIONS FROM
A JOURNALISTIC STANDPOINT TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE SKY.
NUMBER ONE, IN THE ENTIRE PIECE,
THERE IS NO BLANKET EXPLICIT
DENIAL ON THE PART OF EPPS TO
HAVE BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH ANY
INTELLIGENCE GROUP MY DHS, J.T.
TF, MILITARY INTELLIGENCE, SO
FORTH, JUST REITERATES IS VERY
LEGAL DENIAL OF BEING INVOLVED
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT.
NUMBER TWO, THE PIECE DESCRIBES
EPPS AS OF TRUMP SUPPORTER.
HE JUST WENT TO D.C. TO DEFEND
TRUMP AND TO ATTEND THE SPEECH
ON A LAST MINUTE THING WITH HIS
SON TO ATTEND THE SPEECH ON
ELECTION FRAUD.
THE ONLY THING IS, EPPS DIDN'T
ATTEND THE SPEECH.
EPPS TRAVELS ALL THE WAY FROM
ARIZONA TO D.C., THIS BIG TRUMP
SUPPORTER, AND HE DOESN'T EVEN
ATTEND THE SPEECH?
INSTEAD, HE FIXATES ON THIS
BIZARRE MISSION TO GET EVERYONE
TO GO INTO THE CAPITOL?
AND BY THE WAY, JUST HAPPENS TO
BE HANGING OUT RIGHT BY THE
INITIAL BREACH POINT NEAR THE
MONUMENT ON THE WEST SIDE OF
THE CAPITOL BEFORE THE PROUD
BOYS EVEN GET THERE?
AND THIRDLY, WHERE DID RAY EPPS
GET THIS IDEA?
THIS WHOLE PIECE DOESN'T EXPLORE
THAT QUESTION AT ALL.
HERE'S THE ONE PERSON CALLING
FOR EVERYONE TO GO IN.
WHERE DID YOU GET THAT IDEA, RAY
EPPS?
DID IT OCCUR 2 OUT OF NOWHERE?
COULD SOMEONE TELL YOU TO DO IT?
THIS PIECE, SHOCKINGLY, DOES NOT
EXPLORE THAT QUESTION AT ALL,
WHICH IS THE PARAMOUNT QUESTION
THAT'S REALLY THE ANIMATING --
THE LEGEND ANIMATED FOCUS OF
JANUARY 6TH COMMITTEE.
THIS IS SO DIRTY.
HIS BEHAVIOR WAS SO EGREGIOUS
THAT HE WAS ONE OF THE FIRST 20
ON THE FBI MOST WANTED LIST,
FEATURED AS A STAR IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"'S OWN
DOCUMENTARY ON JANUARY 6TH, AND
NOW HE'S ON ARRESTED,
UNINDICTED, HE'S THE ONLY
JANUARY 6TH RIOTER ABOUT WHOM
ADAM KINZINGER HAS NICE THINGS
TO SAY AND "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
IS READY PUFF PIECES ABOUT.
USE THE SMOKING GUN OF THESE
ENTIRE INSURRECTION.
>> Tucker: AND THEY GO CRAZY
WHEN YOU ASK SIMPLE QUESTIONS
LIKE WHAT WAS THE ROLE OF
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OR THE
MILITARY IN THIS DAY, AND IT'S
BEEN OUR EXPERIENCE WHEN THEY
WON'T ANSWER A QUESTION AND CALL
YOU NAMES FOR ASKING IT, MAYBE
THERE IS SOMETHI